This homework is about refactoring the bridge successor function.
I want you to write a new function.
We'll call it bsuccessors3, which takes a bridge state as input,
but we're going to represent the states in a different way.
We're going to represent them not as a set that included the light,
because in the old bridge successor function--bridge successor 2--
it just seemed kind of complicated that I had to deal with the special case of are
the elements of the sets on the here and there side--
are they people or are they the light. It just got a little bit overly verbose.
I think maybe there's a better representation, so we're going to try a different representation.
We're going to try one where there is a set of people on the here side,
a set of people on the there side, and then the light is going to be an index.
It's going to be 0 if the flash light, the torch, is on the here side and 1 if it's on the there side.
Then the tuple for the actions is going to be a little bit different.
It's just going to be a set of people--the travelers that are going--then followed by the arrow.